Lila flea versus its fiery fiery what
does fire taste like oh no we're here
today to try the least popular menu
items from Taco Bell
by the way it's least popular according
to a BuzzFeed quiz that we made not like
shul sales science or whatever do you
eat it talked about a lot I don't really
eat at Taco Bell so this'll be
interesting I've only been to Taco Bell
like twice in my life really yeah
Wow I would have pegged you for a Taco
Bell guy I go there quite often you know
if it's 3 a.m. on a Friday night and I'm
driving down the street and I see Taco
Bell I love a pizza hut in that same
situation I say quiero Taco Bell oh no
ok bring it on
oh these are the fiery Doritos locos
taco these are the least favorite so
only 7% of people on the quiz voted for
this as their favorite which I've come
to surprise by and I mean look how red
this thing is I mean I know the kids and
love these things you do not to lick
your fingers after this yeah they
probably even good they just the cheeto
powder that Dorito powder Oh
oh really love that's not even that
fiery it's just kind of like red but is
it not even spicy that's not I mean like
on a scale of one to ten this is not
even like this guy's hung on the fingers
Oh way to go we have a lot more hmm in
gang always popular special item yeah
what's it called oh it's called a mecs
emotes it's kind of like a pouch Oh mine
stuck to it that's gross
look at that it's stuck
this looks like one of the things I will
order with my Crunchwrap supreme just as
like a side thing you know it was like
oh I'm not sure bigger don't show the
inside don't ever look at the inside
although don't look at the inside only
8% of people apparently won't be further
Mexico as their favorite alright here we
go
I forgot all tomato literally all tomato
no I mean honestly I think this is like
this is pretty bad like this is you know
it is this is this kid Peter the guy on
anything that you put some meat on and
it's a lot I just get soggy if this were
just meat and cheese be delicious but
the tomatoes and it's just
and they don't work I have the opposite
opinion my first thought was oh the
tomatoes really make this yeah because I
have something green here between how
the cheese onion tomato stop opening it
they're just I'm trying to see what else
is in here okay so this is the beefy
Fritos burrito
I actually know this one this cost a
dollar so I can see why it's I don't
know actually I don't see what's the
blue popular it would cost a dollar yeah
that's right say this is like you're
gonna man a food for a buck feels dense
it does fell down like you try it's just
burrito
you know I talked to you on that bike
all this extra all the extra styling I
kind of like the extra extra back my
boyfriend so I said Justin Bieber great
wide only 7% of people like this one all
right so what was the first one the
first one on this was other Crunchwrap
Supremes to be better than this
I don't know I recently had a crunch at
school it was pretty bomb a little
sleeper hit that's a bit this is good
and people are sleeping on I see why
this is the least favorite for sure I
don't understand why this is the least
favorite yeah yeah this is like putting
chips in your sandwich least popular
dessert this is the orange cream pop
freeze what's your favorite flavor of
Fanta my favorite flavor of Fanta yes
great orange is the best you know that
is something I have a huge sweet tooth
that is incredibly sweet today yeah it
doesn't look like a fresh orange yes but
you're just more Marty but it's like if
they just use the orange syrup that they
put an orange soda and they took out the
water yeah and then only three percent
of people said this is their favorite
that's sad cuz this is so good
I'm surprised mmm-hmm maybe they just
haven't tried it they should give us
true
I cook them to be fair though it
literally does taste like you took like
a creamsicle and melted it down and
added ice yeah sure but as a as a drink
as a dessert no I'm still drinking
though it is what's that something that
is I was so impressed to talk about all
these things
yeah I wasn't mad at anything it was all
so good yeah it's just meat she isn't
another thing and it's Taco Bell if you
like talk about you're gonna like these
like I think it's really hard to go
wrong with a Taco Bell you know it's
just like some flour you got some softer
hard shell taco and you got some meat
Usmaan cheese you know I mean it's I
guess hard to go wrong
that one Mexi taxi I'm not really
feeling that one so you can go I want to
try it all all the tacos duster he lived
I licked
I'll be talking to you like yeah
[Music]